the first architecture that shows the
advantage of a convolution based neural
network. We added a few modern flavor
using batchorm and we achieved a very
good performance of unfashion mnist but
the problem is still this is a large
model compared to its depth and its
limitation. It uses only one um filter
size 5x5. uh but here in this session we
will talk about ways to capitalize on
this performance while making it simpler
and develop huristics for better
designs. Just a footnote that after
lenet Alexate came and it did increase
the the depth and added different filter
sizes with a very similar architecture.
Though back in that time they had to
chop the model in two to manage the GPU
aspects. We don't have that problem now
and uh basically if you look at lenet
Alexent is a deeper version of this with
an additional 3x3 convolution in the
next sliders. Okay. So let's ask these
questions first. Why we are using 5x5
kernels in linet? Can we use a smaller
filter? So smaller filter means less
parameters, right? Then how can we
increase the depth of the network
without the vanishing gradient and then
looking at the parameters usage in the
model? Where is the bottleneck? Where
are the most parameters? How can we
reduce them? And then how to make our
life easier? Coming up with blocks in
this design. So a block is a combination
of layers that can be repeated and we
know that that block is highly optimized
and if we stack them in a in a organized
way we can achieve a good performance
while having a bird eye on the design
without getting lost in things that we
already improved and we don't want to
redesign them. So to answer these
questions we are going to go through a
few architectures. We start from VGG and
then we build on top of on top on that
and then we get to changes that lead to
other architectures. Okay. So let's
start with VG. VG tried to answer the
first question. They basically show that
3x3 convolutions when stack on top of
each other can give us the same
receptive field as bigger size
convolutions with less parameters. So
for example here a stack of 3x3 a two
layer 3x3 not only gives us the same
receptive field as one 5x5 with less
parameters it also infuse more
nonlinearity than this with one layer.
So notice that we will have one
injection of nonlinearity here and one
here via the activation functions. So if
the number of channels in and out is the
same the 3x3 number of parameter the 3x3
gives us 18 multiply by channel squared
versus 25 in the 5x5 case. So in fact if
we add another layer of 3x3 then we will
have almost the same parameters 5x5 with
more receptive field and much more nar
nonlinearity. So the idea was let's make
a block with this stack of 3x3's with
padding and max pooling for our
convolution parts of the network and
then just stack them on top of each
other. So let's compare this idea with
the Alex net that we discussed in the
previous slide. So here first look at
the alexn net. So like I said Alex net
is a architecture that is very similar
to linet. It has more convolution with
different filter sizes. So recall that
uh leet was on the amnes data but here
Alex that was developed for image net
competition and back then it smoked the
competition really with a large margin.
However this is like I said a very very
large network with many parameters and
of course this stack of different
convolution. So note that the
convolution layers are in blue here with
their max pools needs to have a lot of
ablation and good design to make these
choices. What VG is offering here is
I'll give you a block. You don't need to
really do a lot of work here because
this is highly optimized. We showed that
this can do more impact than the
alternatives with larger convolution
filters. So note that 3x3 is the
smallest convolution yet. So we are
looking at the smallest convolution unit
a group of them with good padding and
max pooling and once you have this block
just stack them on top of each other and
give it to your classification head. So
why this is very significant in design
because of its ease of implementation.
We basically repeat the same structure
in a for loop and give it to our
forward. So with that let's go ahead and
implement this. We are going to
implement the block and show some
aspects of it. Okay, with that we are
going back to our code um still fashion
emnest loaders and the train one epoch
evaluate. Uh we still have the advanced
MLP which I removed because we don't
need that anymore. Uh but we are going
to use some of this helper functions.
Okay, but before going forward let me
just write a function that count the
parameters of the model. This will be
useful when we are trying to discuss the
changes in the model architectures. So
now we want to make a VG block. So if
you remember a VG block is a stack of
3x3 convolutions with uh of course max
pooling. But in each one of these 3x3s
we have a bash norm and a reloop. So
maybe even before making the block of
VG, we can make a block of 3x3
convolution dash umbrella, right? That's
the smallest component this the atom
that we will build other blocks with.
Right? So first let's build build this
and then build the VG plug and then we
can go to our the VG network. So with
that going to write a convolution batch
norm and here I see that uh the
suggestion is to go with default which
we can of course uh but here since we
don't want to redo something we already
know that let's just try something else.
While this is absolutely okay you can of
course do that but here for the sake of
trying to be more savvy with this block
design let's just go with a more
abstract design. So I'm going to
directly ask for sequential and uh takes
the channel in channel out kernel 3
padding one stride one and um and here
we have bias false. So bias is false
because we are not going to need bias.
The batch norm already has a bias within
it. uh we really don't need and we can
actually even consider this in a lower
level when we are uh building the
convolution itself. So just consider
remember that and here as you can see
this is also a suggestion meaning that I
could directly list the modules that I
want that this sequential needs together
and if I do this I really don't need a
forward method because it does it by
itself. So this is just a clean to make
it even more minimal. I'm going to just
change this rotation. I'm going to send
this to a lower level because I do want
to control it. Less is more always. And
I'm going to make the relu in place to
save some memory. Okay. So that's our
convolution globe. Now I'm going to use
that to make our VG block. Okay. So and
my EG block. Let's just go default with
this. So this is the number of
convolutions we want within the block
and or I in number of convolutions of
course the range of that we want to
append this layers right. Uh so maybe we
should initiate this earlier. Going to
just make it empty but you saw the
suggestion and the reason more clear
here. Want the first layer to have its
own um channel input to be independent
from the others as we can use this black
block anywhere. So the in channels or
each one of this layers that I'm going
to append will be C in if it's the first
layer and it will be see out if it's the
intermediate layers. Okay, so that's the
reason and we are going to append them
all together. So note that I really I
could do the and then sequential again
here and if I did that I didn't I I was
not forced to write a forward method. I
didn't do it. Well, you can do it
yourself or maybe practice but here I
have to write them forward.
>> Okay. So here um just uh maybe a design
point I I'd really like to separate my
convolution stack from my max pooling
stack. And uh this way I will be able to
for example maybe I may want to change
change my pooling to average or I want
to have choice later to do some
ablation. So to do that let's just
change the the appending strategy and uh
separate the pooling here and let's call
this colony and then we have the pool
separate. So in that case we now have to
change this. Okay. Now let's um test um
for an input image of two channel or
maybe one channel just like fashion
emist grayscale and let's say we have
two images in a in a batch. What happens
if we send that through this VG that has
two convolution? Of course, we can
increase that if we want. And let's say
that we are asking for 32 different
features. So 32 channels in the output.
So if we do that, what will be the size
of the output? So basically, if I have a
image, let's just make a random torch
and then send it to the VG block. I'm
asking what's the shape of Y. So pause
the video, think about this. So the
output will be 14 by 14 and the result
is of course the pooling. So now that we
have this, we good to go. We can write
our first VG neural network. So to do
that, uh let's just call it a VG
simpler. Let's go just with two VG
blocks and then a simple classification.
It should be easy. So the F in it uh
let's specify the uh number of classes
convolution layers basically split out
the features for our classification
layer. The sequential of one BG block
132 two convolution and another one with
the input channel of 32 that is the
output of the previous one and 64. Okay
so the output of this one will be a 7 by
7. Okay let's just make it even smaller
because it's supposed to be simple. So
just just show that we have control over
this VG blocks. Okay, that's it. That's
the convolution stack. Let's make the
classifier sequential that flattens the
input destroys all of the spatial
information. But we don't care because
we are giving features. It's already
encoded with our convolution. Okay, it
takes in the input and this will blow
out to be very a lot of parameter. So
let's just simplify this. 128
128 done with the classifier. Then let's
write a four. Now let's just check the
number of parameters and we have uh half
a million parameter here. This is still
a lot. So we have to do something about
this. Let's go back to our quest here.
So we reduced the number of parameters
in our convolution stack compared to the
previous architectures Linux or AlexNet.
But if we look closely in our stack, we
always increase the number of channels.
So this is like increasing the number of
features aka the number of dimensions.
So even if we reduce the height and
widths, if this reduction is not with
the same speed, eventually this will
blow up and at the end we are still
dealing with this dimensionality
problem. Channels is basically the
determining reason for the number of
flops too. If you increase a channel
from one to two or anything beyond one,
it's now you're dealing with a
multi-dimensional cube that you're doing
a convolution over. So that's why it's
the bottleneck of our computation. So we
really want to control this channels. So
we are going to talk about an idea that
we haven't yet thought about and it's
basically pulling across the channel and
to do that we will introduce this one by
one convolutions. So let's start with
this. So the idea is rather simple for
example if you had only one channel you
look at just that feature for each pixel
and you basically multiply it by comp
and a scaler doesn't do anything right.
But what if you have more than one
channel? In that case, you can pull
across that channels for that pixel. So
everything is for one pixel. There's no
spatial mixing. And then for that one
pixel, we look at this features
corresponding features in that channel
and we come up with a a linear waiting
with a bias. And remember this is
basically the linear regression. So we
make a linear regression over the values
of the channels corresponding to that
pixel and we report the output. So this
output can be one dimensional or more
and that's the new channel for us. If
you add a nonlinearity or an activation
to this you basically have out your
perceptron. So that's why this is a mini
LP. For each pixel we make a mini LP and
we output new channels like this. This
channel can be one or more but usually
this is less than the number of initial
channels. Of course it can be more but
usually it's less. And that's how we
shrink the channels while not losing any
information without processing. We are
not dropping any information. We're just
summarizing it with our tools which here
is a linear regression plus an
linearity. And notice that we also
inject some nonlinearity here. We always
in our design this is the principle
always we inject as much as possible
nonlinearity to increase the capacity of
our networks. So hence there are names
uh for the same technique we have
different names for it feature map
pooling cross channel parametric pooling
and so many other names for it. But if
you remember most of the parameters that
we had in all of the designs so far are
actually living in the classification
head. So if we go back comparing the
classification head number of parameters
to the rest of the network for example
in this case probably 80% or maybe 90%
of the parameters are in the
classification and we know why.
Basically in each convolution stack the
number of parameters is the number of
values in the filter. We have one small
network that we do the convolution. It's
very small but compared to this fully
connected MLPS they are not really the
bottleneck. So we have to find a way to
reduce this. This is where we can do the
most damage to the number of parameters.
And this technique here let us do that.
Once we mix the information in the
channels, we can use it to directly
summarize and send to the class uh to
the classification result. So the idea
is the output of this one by ones which
will be a bunch of features like I said
these are the output which is a mixture
of the features that the convolution
finds. We don't need to really do do the
mixing again in a fully connected neural
network. I just directly give it to a
pooling for example averaging and
aggregate all of this information
together. So what we achieved here we
achieved a lot of nonlinearity with not
many parameters through this one by one
layers and we decreased the
classification head size significantly.
Okay, with that let's go on and do the
implementation of this one by one
convolutions and um just a note on the
name network in network it's because of
this MLPS that are leaving across the
channels. So we are going to keep the
same naming the class name black block
takes inherit all module and then what
we need inside this we don't need the
kernel size because it's always one by
one we just need the channel input and
channel output since we can have
multiple of them of this nin blocks ni
uh convolutions within one n block. So
I'm going to specify um the different
channel that we can have different
channel size in the intermediate one by
once. Okay. So let's just think about
three different channel size simplify
for a little let's actually add special
mixing at the first kind of pianu. So
then padding one and now we can do the
mixing of the channels. This will be
convolution. But when we say kel one and
this is the next one by one and we need
another rebel.
Okay. So let's check this out.
We forget a comma here.
So what we expect here? We expect that
since we're not messing up the the image
size and this common be in the loop and
the rest is basically per pixel. There's
no spatial changing. So the output will
be the same spatial and we can control
the channels with whatever channel size
that we want to be in the middle or
output. Remember the initial one is just
the the raw input channel. Okay. So
let's make the network. So name simpler
NN module takes in the number of
classes. It's a sequential of an NN
block. Then we do a max pull over this.
Then another block. Let's just make it
simpler. And then another max pull.
Okay. So then we need a classification
head which is uh implemented by an
adaptive average pooling. We could do
average pooling without adaptive but
basically we have to take care of all of
these heights and weights even maybe in
different batches. Uh here adaptive it
be bins the heights and weights in a way
that average the value of that channel
in those beans and output that and send
it to the classifier and the classifier
is basically a linear regression fully
connected classification linear
regression takes in 64 features gives
out the logic values for each classes.
Now the folder.
That's it. Let's count the number of
parameters here.
Okay, there's an error here.
Oh, I see. But got 32 got 64.
Okay.
So let's compare the number of
parameters between the NIN simpler and
the VGG. And as you will as you see
here, we're looking at half a million
compared to 30,000.
That's a huge difference.
Okay. So to do the training uh here I
repeated the code from before the
auxiliary code that we wrote for the
loaders and training and recall that we
use the transform to tensor for both uh
training and validation data when we are
feeding feeding to the model. Here I
want to use this movement to add u
another concept that basically is called
data augmentation.
So the idea is for image data we have
this convolutional neural network that
gives a translation equivalence for us
but we want the model to be able to do
the detection for an image that is taken
night or during the day. So these two
image have different lighting condition
different colors and we want the model
to be invariant to them too. So in those
cases what we can do is to just feed the
model with images in those condition and
because the labeling are the same we
expect the model to become robust
against those variations. So here we can
look at a horizontal flip. For example,
if you have a cat and you flip the
image, it is still a cat. And you can
also add some
probability that every
uh in every 10 image
flip one of them when you're feeding to
the model.
The common one like for example we can
do random rotation for example.
We can do cropping, random crop, random
pie. They all keep the same. But it's
important to remember
we only augment the data during
training, not during validation.
And sometimes uh when uh we use
pre-trained model uh we should be more
strategic in the way that we are doing
this augmentation. For example, two
strong transformation. If you change the
angle for for example for a building it
may break the class identity. So it's
important to know how strong should be
this augmentation. Uh sometimes it
doesn't really help a lot in feature
learning because we have a very strong
pre-trained model that already does a
great job in feature learning. We only
need to change the classification.
So we may not need this augmentation. So
like I said it is important to decide
where to use it.
Okay.
So with that let's do the training.
Okay. There is an error. Let's see
what's going on. Imp place operation.
Something is wrong with our rel. Let's
go back.
Oh, I see we have relution
and re. So we don't need this. That's
not the case in VGC. Uh okay, great. So
this should do it.
So I see the results are back and let's
just look at the validation accuracy
here and the VG is going up and we
already broke the 90%. with just a few
epochs and we see a respectable
performance for the networking network
almost as good as linet and remember
compare the number of parameters we're
achieving that with much less parameters
to care of two situations one was the
blow up of the dimension with this one
by ones the other one was taking care of
this many parameters in the fully
connected classification head and then
we came up with these blocks that can do
optimal performance while help us doing
our designs. So the next important
modification is how can we achieve
deeper architecture
that's where the idea of inception nets
uh comes in. So back then we still
didn't have ResNet, a way to go deeper
without gradient vanishing. But now that
we have this one by one convolution, it
basically took care of blockers for us
to go with more layers. We took care of
the blow up. Now we can stack more
layers. We know how to deal with heights
and weights with padding and pulling.
And we now can control the number of
channels with this one by ones. And now
with that we will talk about this new
architecture. And don't worry we will
zoom in into this blocks. But the idea
here is we can stack many convolution
and this inception blocks because of all
this advancement that we had so far. So
this is developed by Google. There is a
lenit reference here for respect. But
the idea is here now that we can b
budget the parameters we can go deeper.
And the other idea is we can also keep
different scales in our convolution.
Maybe if we look at different spatial
scale at once we may find better
features. So when we zoom in into the
inception block firstly we have this one
by ones that manage the the shape makes
the channels prevents explosion of the
dimensionality and then feed that to
these two different kernamel sizes and
they are looking at the image uh
simultaneously speed out the found
features and we concatenate all of these
found features. So note that we have the
one by one's if you think about it it's
like a residual really uh it doesn't do
any convolution after that and then we
have another channel here basically
pulls the information and gives to a one
by one. All of these branches have their
own nonlinearity injected and here the
principles that we achieve is first of
all we are not committed to a single
scale we are using different kernels.
The height and widths will be preserved.
Of course we will have many channels
because we concatenate all of this. The
pooling channel here is also gives a
shortcut about the context. For example,
if it's an average like the average
context or if it's smacks the most
dominant uh concepts that can talk to
the other features later. This way we
solve this cost of going deeper to some
extent. There's a lot of parallel
computation. Of course, we inject a lot
of nonlinearity with not a lot of
parameters. So cheap nonlinearity still
factoriz kernel smaller kernels stacking
together. And long story short, this was
not enough even after all of this. And
that's where residual connections came
in and resolved the depth problem. Okay,
so to recap about ResNet, if you
remember, we just add skip connection
and learn only the FX here plus an X
that we don't need to learn. Just a
recap on what we can achieve with this
uh baselines. For example, the net had
about 60k about 45k of it was in the
classification head. We achieved 89% uh
validation accuracy but of course this
is a large network. Then we discussed VG
which uh about the same number of
parameters but of course with more depth
and it gives us I I would argue more
than 90% and we just showed it in our
code here even with seven epochs we can
go even higher and then the networking
network again here we see that it's
going up. Of course, if we continue the
epoch, we may get even better
performance.
And we are getting close to linet with
much less parameters. And then if we go
for resets again deeper architectures,
you can hit even more and more
validation accuracy. And we will see
that uh in the assignment. Okay. So like
I said, the idea is let's use all of
let's go for an architecture that is
even smaller but with a respectable
performance. And the idea is we want to
put this model on a on a phone for
example on an edge device. And we know
there are some limitations for example
this much memory that we can use. So the
model cannot be larger than this many
parameters. So we want to be able to do
our best with that given constraint. We
want to engineer the model using all of
these tips and tricks and principles
that we learned. So we should know what
are the extremes that we can go and then
play within these extremes. So that's
where the mobile nets come in. Like I
said, these networks were designed for
mobile or edge devices where we have
this constraint of very small RAM tight
latency and the budgets on energy
battery power. So we have to reduce the
number of parameters a lot without
killing really the accuracy. We still
want the spatial inductive bias. So we
still need convolution. Let's go from
this standard convolution where we do KK
convolution and instead of doing this
let's look at each channel each input
channel for example in the case of RGB
look at RG and B separately and do KK on
each one of these filter by Kami KK
convolution and then mix the channels
separately for each pixel that's the N I
style basically one one convolution so
this way we split the spatial compute
from the channel mixing and this will
reduce the number of parameters
significantly. For example, in the case
of standard one here we have this many
parameters but if we separate them we
basically break the C out outside of
this we're looking at about 10 times
fewer parameters in a small block and
when you stack them we're talking about
exponentially less parameters. So like I
said we will explore this ideas.
So with all of these advances and all of
this data the image data that we have
out there some of these models achieve
very good very good performance and we
know that most of the features that we
can find in in images are shared across
different objects. The idea is well why
should we retrain this convolution
stacks or at least the early layers of
it well when they are doing the same
thing. So why don't we just go ahead and
train a very good design stack of
convolution layers and then use it for
our classification per purposes. Maybe
we just train the classification ad. So
this idea is transfer learning and uh it
means that we can copy a trained model
freeze it uh we are not allowing any
back propagation through its weight and
we only back prop through our linear
layers. we can generate a very large
data set for example imageet that has
about 14 million images and 1,000
classes which requires a lot of time and
compute to to train a model on this. But
if we already have a model that has the
weights trained for us that can work as
a prior for us. So we will keep this
prior and use it in our pipeline. And if
we have more data we will train more.
will go back and train. So for example,
if we only train the head of this class
head of this network, the classifier, we
call this a linear probe. We basically
use the feature extraction and we linear
probe. If we want to train more, we want
to go back more, we call it fine-tuning.
For example, if we use a model that is
trained on image nets with only a few
epoch, we can achieve a 93% performance
on fashion data. And we can if we have
if we use more data from fashion, we can
even fine-tune the last block and
achieve 94%. But we'll see that in the
assignment. Okay. So let's uh do a
transfer learning and resonate
architecture that is available from
torch vision. So we will use the reset
18 architecture. U so 18 comes from the
18 layer of the network and you see that
there are two different blocks here. If
you look up at figure 863, the first
block has this uh basic block that is
very similar to what we wrote kind of a
3x3 a batch norm relu kind of batch norm
and uh relu here is not present. It's of
skip and then relu. So that's the
difference from the previous block that
we wrote. Okay, going back here. So we
are going to use this. There's m here
that we are not touching. Most of these
layers will not be touched during the
transfer learning. We're going to do
linear probe for FC. And if we want to
do fine tuning, we may hold one of this
last convolution layer. Okay. So with
that, let's go to the code. Okay. So you
see that in torch vision models, I'm
importing reset 18 model and its
weights. Note that here in the
augmentation I put some transfers to to
make sure the ResNet 18 works with our
fashionist data because remember that
the reset 18 is trained on imageet.
Okay, with that the rest is basically
like before and we are going to the
model. So for now we are freezing the
entire reset 18 and weights. So we are
not activate gradients on that. So if we
have freeze all it means that we are
just linear probing. So all of them
parameters
will be frozen.
So model here is res 18 trunk and here
for the FC part we release the gradient
and basically we allow gradient if we
want to fine-tune. So if we have enough
data to go and deeper and train the last
convolution layer the layer four we can
do this. So we allow a function here. So
for linear probe like I said we are just
training the FC and for finetune we also
train the the last layer. The important
thing here is we have different learning
rate for the backbone and the head. uh
when we are doing fine-tuning we allow
larger learning rate for the for the
classification head and very
conservative learning rate for the force
layer of convolution that's it we can do
the training and test this out so this
takes some time but since you guys have
a similar result in the assignment I'm
going to stop Yeah.